what is the theory of everything what
does the theory of everything seek to
accomplish
well i mean this is very much a kind of
reductionist point of view in the sense
that so it's not a theory this is not
going to explain to you you know
anything it doesn't really this kind of
theory theory this kind of theory of
everything we're talking about doesn't
say anything interesting particularly
about like macroscopic objects about
what the weather is going to be tomorrow
or
you know things are happening at this
scale but
just what we've discovered is that as
you look at um
the universe that kind of
you know if you
kind of start brit you can start
breaking it apart into and you end up
with some fairly simple pieces quanta if
you like and which are doing which are
interacting in some fair in some fairly
simple way
and it's um
it's good so what we mean by the theory
of everything is
a theory that describes all
all the object all the correct objects
you need to describe what's happening in
the world and describes how they're
interacting with each other at a most
fundamental level
how you get from that theory to
describing some macroscopic incredibly
complicated thing is there that becomes
again more of an engineering problem and
you may need machine learning or you
made you know a lot of very different
things to do it but i don't even
think it's uh just engineering it's also
science it one thing that i find
um
kind of interesting
talking to physicists is is a little bit
there's a
a little bit of hubris
so some of the most brilliant people i
know are physicists both philosophy and
just in terms of mathematics in terms of
understanding the world
but there's a kind of uh either hubris
or what would i call it
uh
like a confidence that if we have a
theory of everything we will understand
everything like this is the deepest
thing to understand and i would say
and like the rest is details right
that's the the old rutherford thing uh
but
to me
there's like this is like a cake or
something there's layers to this thing
and each one has a theory of everything
yeah like at every level
from biology like how life originates
that itself like complex systems yeah
like
that in itself is like this gigantic
thing that requires a theory of
everything and then there's the in the
space of humans psychology like
intelligence collective intelligence the
way it emerges among species
that feels like a complex system that
requires its own theory of everything
on top of that
is things like in the computing space
artificial intelligence systems like
that feels like it is a theory of
everything and it's almost like
um once we solve
once we come up with a theory of
everything that explains the basic laws
of physics that gave us the universe
even stuff that's super complex like uh
how like how the
universe might be able to originate even
explaining something that you're not a
big fan of like multiverses or stuff
that we don't have any evidence of yet
still we won't
be able to
have a strong explanation
of uh
why
food tastes delicious oh yeah yeah i
know no anyway yeah i agree completely i
mean this
there is something kind of completely
wrong with this terminology or theory of
everything that it's not um it's really
in some sense very bad term very
hubristic and bad
terminology because it's not um this is
explaining
this is a purely kind of reductionist
point of view that you're you're trying
to understand
certain a certain very specific kind of
things which
you know in principle
other things
you know emerge from but
to actually understand how anything
emerges from this is it's hope it can't
be understood in terms of
this this underlying fundamental theory
is going to be
hopeless in terms of kind of telling you
what about this um
this various emergent behavior and as
you go to different levels of
explanation you're going to need to
develop new you know different
completely different ideas completely
different ways of thinking and
i guess there's a famous kind of um
phil anderson's
slogan is that you know more is
different and then yeah so it and
it's just it's just
even once you understand how what a
couple things well if you have a
collection of stuff and you understand
perfectly well how each thing is
interacting with it
with the others what the whole thing is
going to do is just a completely
different problem it's just not and you
need completely different ways of
thinking about it
you